then do you so do you feel like that's
for men an unfair deal yes yeah I do wow
that's bigger you to say it's not fair
because I don't believe they should have
to deal with anyone's past trauma yeah
that's been caused by someone else I
think it's amazing if you do meet a man
that wants to be understanding to that
level where they want to try and fix
that or help you to heal but I
definitely don't think it's fair that
women
put their past trauma on someone new
that they meet someone that comes into
their life that hasn't done nothing to
them they might that man might be
amazing it might be great you know but
because we've experienced
bad experiences and we've got that
trauma and that bit of scarring
we project that onto them that's